in georgia a guy called the police
at mcdonald's to complain about his
fries being lukewarm no i try to fry the
fries that look warm but they're not hot
okay we're gonna change these guys can
we get some fresh fresh rocks i can run
my store however i want to run my store
he said matter of fact you can leave my
property get off my property now turns
out the guy who called a police
complaint had outstanding warrants
for a homicide
wow they chase him through the
mcdonald's parking lot and they tase him
and now he's in prison that guy ruined
it for all the other people that are
just trying to call about lukewarm fries
and run in the woods because you're
gonna be like well i gotta assume all of
you killed someone
because the one time i went and chased
him that guy killed someone there's a
little bit too that you want to say from
mcdonald's you all need to get it
together at your places because you're
driving people to this insanity your ice
cream machine's broke your your fries
are not always you know it's on
mcdonald's as much as on that guy
yeah i mean keep it hot keep it hot
there's murderers trying to eat too